quand ils ont acheté cette maison les
nouveaux propriétaires ont respecté ils
n'ont pas touché à la chambre du vert
jusque là et très mystifié cette chambre
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a voulu aussi
ouvrir les portes pour que les gens
puissent vraiment la découvrir et
ensuite nous pouvoir faire un travail
pour la sortir de la maison mais tout en
respectant la volonté de Monsieur et
Madame Rochefort la chambre est au
premier au bout d'un long couloir elle
est restée comme gelée à la mort du
jeune officier en 1918 aujourd'hui ce
morceau d'histoire de France se dégrade
et il est temps d'agir l'objectif c'est
que ce ne soit pas démembré et que ce
soit en intégralité dans son contexte
global là on a les deux vareuses
qui sont fortement mangés par les par
les petites bêtes depuis un siècle
Michel Jouanneau a participé à la
numérisation au préparatifs du
déménagement personne n'était entré ici
jusqu'en 2014 je me disais quand même tu
es en train de violer l'intimité d'un
soldat qui est mort il y a 100 ans
c'est pas c'est pas bien en gros et puis
après je me suis dit mais pour me
rassurer moi tu fais ça pour la bonne
cause parce que ça va rester près de 200
personnes se sont inscrites pour cette
visite très singulière ceux de la
Première Guerre mondiale on les a pas
connues donc on a pas eu ces histoires
donc là ça nous remet quand même à cette
époque là et ouais c'est quand même
impressionnant c'est aussi
impressionnant de voir le respect que
les gens ont pu avoir en achetant cette
maison et à chaque fois en gardant
cette pièce intacte quoi tout est là des
livres un paquet de tabac comme si
Hubert allait revenir c'est un monument
à un soldat connu émet et à la douleur
de sa famille je suis venu visiter ce
lieu en lien avec la Première Guerre
mondiale la même manière que l'année
dernière j'ai amené mes enfants sur le
champ de bataille de Verdun à l'occasion
de vacances parce que voilà c'est un
c'est un lieu important notre histoire
ça dit d'où on vient bientôt la chambre
renaîtra ailleurs pour se souvenir
encore longtemps des poilus de 14-18